uh prevents i think the prime minister
uh uh stressed and matt hancock is
likely to stress
uh people getting severely ill uh and it
appears to uh prevent
uh death so i think that uh the main job
of the
health secretary is to try and dampen
down any concern
uh that the south african variant uh may
be causing
uh some problems with uh with vaccines
uh and reassure people first of all
uh that there are benefits to the south
um even uh facing the south african
variant
uh from having the vaccine and secondly
uh just to
sort of eliminate exactly how the
government is planning to tackle this
uh in future uh we have heard from
scientists in the last couple of days
that one of the
strategies that will be rolled out in
time by the government is that uh
people could in the in effect in the end
by the end of this year
uh get a third jab uh in order which
will contain slightly different
uh version of the vaccine which will be
uh more resistant to
other new mutations of coronavirus like
the south african
variants now uh the health minister ed
argher told
sky this morning that there are 147
cases of the south african variant
in this country now there are tens of
thousands of uh uh
of cases of other strains of coronavirus
other strains like the kent variant that
is uh faster to infect
people by far and away the dominant uh
issue in this country at the moment and
at the moment it looks as if the south
african
uh variant because it's less
transmissible than the kent variant
uh isn't particularly uh spreading at
pace
but that said um epidemiologists have
been warning today that 147
cases figure is likely to be an
underestimate of the number
of south african variants cases in this
country simply because
we can't track south african variant
cases as
easily as we could kent strain variant
because the way
uh that that uh that new mutation has uh
sequenced
uh so and is uh checked and uh shows up
in uh in the tests that are
uh are done uh so i think that's the
primary job of
matt hancock the next thing that he's
going to be doing is talking about
today's
vaccine rates now um we understand that
uh
today has seen a rise of 278
988 uh people getting the back seat up
to uh february the 7th which is uh
yesterday
now that's a little bit below the
average of uh the last week partly
uh because most of those were done on a
sunday now the uh weekly rolling average
is 428
130 a day but it'll be interesting to
see just as we
approach the 15 million target due on
february the 15th although some
uh many think that it could come earlier
than that whether or not the government
has something to say about the fact that
uh there was slight undershoot yesterday
government working very hard to ensure
that all over 70s get the uh
the first coronavirus jab that was the
thing that the prime minister promised
would happen
when he put england back into its third
lockdown
at the start of january
but there are lots of associated issues
with that that matt hancock might
uh be facing questions on when he stands
up next to jonathan uh van tam and nikki
cannani of
nhs england one of the most interesting
stories debates really
is whether or not it will be ethical for
employers to force their employees to
take the vaccine
uh in order to continue uh working this
follows uh
the reports that some care home staff
are demanding that their employees
uh take the vaccine before returning uh
to work and charlie
mullins the founder of pimlico plumbers
said last month that his company
will not take on uh anyone who is
vaccinated now
uh downing street has today said that it
wouldn't be ethical
uh to force people to have the
coronavirus vaccine
in order to keep their job it'll be
interesting to see uh whether or not
that
uh is um yet another uh subject that
comes up at the press conference
uh but i think that as we uh are heading
into what are we about a week out from
where the government
uh promises to review uh coronavirus
restrictions uh in order to publish a
road map on february the 22nd
uh boris johnson will come to the uh
houses of parliament to the commons two
weeks today in order to set out his
preliminary thinking
on how the various restrictions will be
lifted in the weeks and months to come
i suspect that once again as we do in
almost all of these press conferences
uh have questions uh around that and
some of the weekend papers
uh we're talking about some of the
measures that the government are
considering
uh doing it looks as if in england there
is no chance that schools will reopen
before march the 8th
of course in scotland and in wales
that both of those devolved governments
have promised to
ease the return pupils to school uh a
week or two
uh earlier than those in england which
are they're going to stick with
march the 8th and then it seems as if
the government at the moment is minded
to go at really quite a slow pace when
it comes to reopening
initially looking at uh outdoor events
sporting
uh uh sort of allowing people to gather
in small groups in order to play
uh sport and the safety of outdoors and
then pushing
uh reopening of non-essential shops
maybe back into
april late april uh possibly even into
may for some forms of hospitality
um all of that because the prime
minister has made it a primary aim and i
hear that this is
uh something he's quite insistent on in
meetings uh inside number 10
that this will be the last lockdown he
says now he has said that before but
he's adamant
uh that he doesn't want to see uh as it
were a
third spike of coronavirus having gone
through uh two
uh big waves the second wave of course
that we're in at the moment bigger
than the first and now to see the roll
out of the vaccine he doesn't want to
have to contemplate
uh restrictions once more but those who
are listening to last week's press
conferences
will remember chris witte being
incredibly forthright
saying that you might not want to
contemplate it but bluntly when it comes
to the winter
uh coronavirus as a respiratory disease
is very likely to come roaring back
through communities just as
winter flu does possibly necessitating
more social distancing restrictions back
then so you do have this conundrum
inside government
where there is potentially a public
expectation that you'll get your two
coronavirus jabs
have to wait a few weeks and then uh out
and restrictions can be lifted but the
scientists are quite clear that the
situation with coronavirus partly
because of these new
mutations is more complex than that
and particularly if you see some of the
vaccine resistant qualities of the south
african
mutation combining with some of the
transmissibility increases the speed
with which
uh it's increased if the kent factory if
you see of the kent variant if you see
those two qualities
uh combining in uh in a new mutation
then
uh the chances are that medics and
scientists could have something of a
challenge
on their hands requiring more thought
going into
a new vaccine in order to sort of tackle
that now the government itself is also
putting in quite a lot of work into
combating
exactly that there are some inside
government who talk of
uh being able to manufacture new strains
of vaccines in just 40 days from uh
arrival of the new variant to
approval of the new vaccine that's the
kind of speed that they're
working at in order to tackle these
things but i think
this is the thing that scientists worry
most that whilst the government is
signaling
a way out it might be more complicated
than that and here is matt hancock
good afternoon and welcome back to
downing street for today's coronavirus
briefing
and i'm joined by the deputy chief
medical officer professor jonathan van
tam
and by nhs england's medical director
for primary care
dr nikki kanani before i update you
on the coronavirus response i'd just
like to take you through the latest data
if i could have the slide please
there are still 29 326
patients with kovid in hospitals across
the uk
and as you can see from this slide that
is still more
than either the april or at the november
peaks
and sadly 841 deaths
have been reported on average each day
over the past week
my thoughts are with everyone who's lost
a loved one to this deadly disease
today i'd like to update you on three
important parts of the coronavirus
response
the first is our next steps on the
vaccination program
it's now two months to the day since
margaret keenan
got her first jab the first person
in the world to be vaccinated with a
clinically authorized vaccine for
coronavirus
we have now as of today vaccinated more
than 12.2
million people that's almost one in four
of all adults across the united kingdom
take up of the vaccine so far has been
significantly better than we hoped for
based on the work we'd done before the
vaccination program started
and looking at the surveys we knew that
the uk
had one of the most positive attitudes
to
vaccine uptake but even so we thought
we'd get take up of around 75
i'm really pleased to be able to tell
you that as of midnight last night
among the over 80s we've now given a
first dose
to 91
among those aged between 75 and 79
it's 95 and almost
three-quarters of those aged between 70
and 74
who were the most recent group to be
invited
we've also visited every eligible care
home with older residents
and offered vaccinations to all their
residents and staff
so among eligible care home residents
the take-up is
93 but will not rest
until we vaccinate all those in the most
at-risk groups because vaccines
save lives they protect you
and there's increasing evidence that
they protect all those around you as
well
the fewer people who are left
unvaccinated
the safer will all be and the more
securely
we'll be able to release restrictions
when the time is right
i've been thrilled to see so much
enthusiasm about coming forward for a
jab
and i'm just so pleased that take up has
been so high
but we're not going to rest until all
those who are vulnerable have been
protected
so the nhs and local authorities and the
teams working with them
are doing everything they can to reach
the remaining people in these at-risk
groups
and we'll keep on searching for those
final few percent
even as we expand the offer of a vaccine
to younger age groups
and i'm going to ask dr kanani to say a
few words
more about this project in a moment
we're on track to meet our goal of
offering a vaccine to everyone
in priority groups one to four by the
15th of february which is one week today
before moving on to the other jcvi
priority groups
the nhs has worked hard to contact
everyone
in groups one to four but we want to be
certain
so from today i have a message for
everyone
aged 70 and above until now
we've said please wait for the nhs to
contact you
but now that message is changing
if you live in england and are
70 and over and have not yet
got an appointment to be vaccinated then
please
contact the nhs the easiest way to do
this
is through the national booking service
online at
nhs.uk
or if you can't get online then you can
call 119
or you can speak to your local gp
practice
if you're in scotland wales or northern
ireland
we are also on track working together
to meet the goal by the 15th of february
and your local health team will be in
touch
i'm so grateful to the whole team who
are delivering this vaccination program
so brilliantly across the whole united
kingdom
and to everyone who's doing their bit by
bearing their
arms and getting the jab
while we use our vaccination program to
go on the offensive against this virus
it's very important that we keep our
defenses up as well
our testing program has also grown at a
blistering rate
we're now carrying out on average four
and a half
million tests every single week
nhs test and trace is returning 97
of in-person tests by the next day
contact tracing is performing incredibly
well reaching over 97
of contacts where details are given and
98
of those they're reaching within 24
hours
i want to say a massive thank you to the
nhs test and trace team
who built this extraordinary capability
almost from scratch even in lockdown
testing to find out where the virus is
is critical to break the chains of
transmission to find those positive
cases
so people can isolate and stop the
spread
today i'm delighted to be able to
announce another step forward to bolster
our onshore test manufacturing
capability
we're joining forces with the
derby-based manufacturer shaw screen
to deliver 20 million rapid tests which
can produce results in 30 minutes
they'll be using our they'll be used in
our asymptomatic testing program
to identify the around one in three
people who get the virus but have no
symptoms at all
yet can still pass it on this expanded
capacity
means we can offer more regular testing
to even more
people many employers are already taking
up the offer
of rapid regular workplace testing
which has protected critical workers
like in the nhs
and in schools so that they can keep
going
employers who've introduced workplace
testing tell me that
they find it useful for early
identification of people who have
covered
and so the number of
outbreaks reduces as time goes on and so
lowers the number of people
who are off work with covet this is a
really important part
of what we need to do from today we're
expanding the offer of regular workplace
testing to all
businesses with over 50 employees in
sectors that are currently open
testing will become even more important
as we exit lockdown when the time is
right
of course for now you must work from
home if you can
but if you can't we want to make sure
that we're providing as much
certainty and confidence as possible
and i'd urge all eligible employers to
take up this offer
you can go online to the portal gov dot
uk
coronavirus and this will all help to
keep vital services going
and to keep the virus on the back foot
the third thing i want to touch on
is our work to tackle new variants
all viruses mutate over time and part of
controlling any virus is responding
to new variants as they arise we do this
every year with flu for instance
and knowing this we invested in the
genomic
sequencing capability right at the start
of this
pandemic because genomic sequencing is
how you identify
new variants we've given the uk
one of the biggest genomic sequencing
capabilities in the world in fact
the uk has provided almost half of all
of the covid sequences
that have been provided worldwide this
genomic capacity has allowed us to spot
variants here at home
and is allowing us to support others to
detect
variants in other parts of the world we
mustn't let a new variant
undo all of the good work that the
vaccine rollout is doing to protect
people
now the first line of defense is to spot
and suppress
new variants aggressively wherever
they're found
hence the tougher more measures at the
border and the firm action we're taking
in those small numbers of areas where
variants of concern have been found
in the community including door-to-door
communications
and enhanced testing and sequencing at
the same time
since the emergence of variants of
concern late last year
we've been working on how vaccines can
be used to tackle them
it is imperative that our vaccination
program
keeps pace with any changes to this
virus
professor vantam will be saying a little
bit more about what we're doing
the work has three parts
first the evidence is that the existing
vaccines
have some effect against new variants
particularly preventing serious illness
and mortality
so the existing vaccine rollout is
mission critical
for tackling new variants too
second we're working with the existing
max vaccine suppliers
on potential booster jabs targeted
specifically at the new variants to
strengthen
this protection further third we're
building
onshore uk capacity including
cutting-edge
mrna technologies to give us the ability
rapidly to develop and deploy vaccines
against any new variants or similar new
diseases in the future
we've entered into a new partnership
with the vaccine manufacturer
curvac to develop vaccines that can be
quickly adapted
as new strains are identified just as we
do the flu vaccine each year
i am determined that we build this
capacity
right here securely in the uk
to protect everyone across these islands
not just from new variants
now but in the long term too
we've agreed an initial supply of 50
million doses
to add to the 400 million doses that are
already in our vaccine portfolio
so we'll be prepared for whatever the
future might bring
of course the fewer new cases of
coronavirus
that we have the lower the chance
of a new variant appearing domestically
so the essential message to stay at home
and follow the social distancing rules
is our best defense
right now taking all of this together
what i want to say is this the number of
people in hospital
is still far too high but it is falling
the number of people who are dying from
this disease is also
far too high but that is falling too
we're turning a corner in our battle
against coronavirus
the vaccine rollout is going well and if
you're aged
70 and over and haven't been contacted
yet please get in touch now
and all the time we must be vigilant and
do what it takes to tackle any new
variants that arise
for now the most important thing that
you can do
is get the job when your time comes stay
at home
protect the nhs and save lives
i'm now going to turn to dr kanani to
set out
the details on increasing that critical
uptake
and making sure that we reach everybody
who is vulnerable to
coronavirus and what we are doing to hit
the target
of making sure we get an offer to
everybody in
priority cohorts one to four by the 15th
of february
thank you very much um so could i start
today by paying tribute to
my nhs colleagues who have been working
tirelessly behind the scenes
um whether you are planning um the
vaccination program behind a screen or
in an office uh you're a car park
steward shoveling snow
and moving cars around or you're a
member of the practice
management team who is setting up these
clinics you are part of a historic
moment
i know that the adverse weather
conditions have been really tricky
but i also know that that has not
stopped us we have set up over
1500 vaccination sites now around the
country
and that is from mosques to museums from
guradwaras to
games grounds from cathedrals to
community centers
every eligible care home has now had a
visit but if you're in a care home
and you weren't able to have your
vaccination either because as a resident
you'd been unwell or as a member of
staff you weren't quite ready to say yes
we will come back to visit you because
we want to make sure that everyone can
take up this offer
this weekend we were vaccinating almost
28 000 people
every hour that we were operating that
means that we were doing everything we
can
to protect you from this virus
and the snow has not stopped us we've
had teams in skipton
in yorkshire uh gp surgeries have
created eight teams
and over the weekend visited over 300
people in their own houses
so wherever you are however you need the
vaccine
if you're in the priority cohort you
will be offered it
this week we'll be sending out letters
and we'll be making phone calls to make
sure that if you're in that priority
cohort
you will have that offer and if
previously you've had the offer
and you weren't sure and you've changed
your mind now please take up the offer
when you're contacted
because that decision could save your
life
and as secretary of state said until now
we've asked you to wait
because we wanted to contact you for
your vaccination
but if you're over 70 let me be clear
if you've had an offer and you've not
taken it up yet please come forward now
the best way to do this is through the
online booking service
through nhs.uk but if that doesn't work
for you
you can also telephone 119 and i also
know that our teams
made up of gps nurses pharmacists and
more
around the country are waiting to
vaccinate you if you still need your
vaccination this week
can i just remind people that if you're
in the priority groups and you've had
a appointment come through from your gp
and the national booking system
choose one and keep that because it
means that we can make another
appointment
for somebody else so finally the nhs
vaccination program is the most
incredible program that we've rolled out
in history
but we all have a role to play to make
sure that no one gets left behind
so if we've not been in contact with you
and during the priority groups
please get in touch with us thank you
very much
dr kanani and now i'd ask professor van
tam to set out
more details of what we're doing on the
vaccine front
in particular with the new variants
thanks secretary of state
before i say a few words about variants
and vaccines
i'd just like to add my thanks to the
nhs staff and the volunteers as well
who are working the vaccine centers and
whenever i can
get out and put a shift in alongside you
it's an enormous privilege to be able to
do so so thank you
now turning to the variants and vaccines
i'll say a few words particularly about
the south african variant
which in the trade we know as b 1.351
um and because this has been in the in
the news quite a lot in the last few
days so that south african variant 351
is now dominant in south africa
and causing the vast majority of the
cases
that they encounter it has been detected
in the uk
but in very small numbers and it is not
our dominant virus our dominant virus at
the moment
is a variant which was first identified
in kent
which you'll be aware of and we call
that one b 1.117
and um you will know from
what we saw before christmas with the
um 117 variant that
if it has a distinct transmissibility
advantage
over the predecessor then it can
establish itself very quickly indeed
but early data on modeling
of b1.351 does not
suggest this is so does not suggest
that the south african variant has
a distinct transmissibility advantage
over our current virus and because of
that
there is no reason to think the south
african variant
will catch up or overtake our current
virus
in the next few months and that's a
really important point
that being the case our immediate threat
is from our current virus and
there is now plenty of evidence that the
vaccines that we are deploying
are effective against our current
virus so from that perspective
look please don't delay if you're called
take the advantage to protect yourself
against the clear and present danger
against the immediate threat
turning now a bit further afield to the
south african variant
and the future several vaccine
manufacturers
including pfizer the manufacturer of a
vaccine that's deployed here
novovax and janssen with whom the
british government
has arrangements they've already
released
either some preliminary clinical or
serological data
about their vaccines and the south
african variant
and taken as a package they do give me
confidence
that there is still likely to be a
substantial effect of the current
vaccines
in terms of reducing serious illness
even if infections are not as well
prevented
now astrazeneca of course the
uk oxford university vaccine is the one
that has
been in the news most recently but
my feelings about the astrazeneca
vaccine are essentially similar
the south african trial was in young
adults
and reported mild disease
and a reduced level
of protection against infection but that
really
doesn't change my view that it is still
rather likely to have an effect on
severe disease
and to people who are kind of on the
edge going well shall i have this
current vaccine
or should i kind of hang on for you know
a south african variant vaccine when it
arrives
my advice to you is very simple do not
delay have the vaccine that will protect
you against the current threat
and don't worry you can be revaccinated
for people who've had a full course of
two vaccines
a revaccination is probably only going
to require one dose
that requires some science work to
confirm it but that is my hunch
and you can be revaccinated and we're
taking a lot of
steps behind the scenes to ensure that
we can be in that position
so should we be engaged in thinking and
planning behind the scenes
for needing variant vaccines at some
point in the future
absolutely yes just as variations to the
virus were inevitable
it's almost inevitable that we would at
some point need variations to the
vaccine
so this is not a big fright it's not a
big surprise
it's something that we have anticipated
for quite some time
is it therefore reasonable to begin to
frame our longer term
thinking about possibly needing an
annual or a biennial
booster in high-risk groups yes
absolutely it is that's the right way to
frame it
there's no decision has been made not
enough science
information under the bridge yet but
it is definitely the right way to frame
it so if you read the headlines and you
feel a bit panicky
or you think there's some kind of
immediate problem
please try and be reassured the better
watch words are
concern of course we're concerned
vigilance yes we're hyper vigilant
and preparation there is a lot going on
behind the scenes
that will become clearer over the course
of time thank you secretary state
thank you very much professor now we'll
now go to questions from the public and
then we'll turn to questions from the
media the first question from the public
is from samantha from lancashire by
video samantha
when are frontline police officers
likely to receive the vaccine
like paramedics they have to go into
many different houses a day
and there is a high risk of either
taking the virus home or passing to one
of the many elderly or vulnerable people
they come into contact with on a daily
basis
thank you very much samantha a very
important
question and i want to thank police
colleagues who are doing so much to
protect us at this time including making
sure
that the rules that we have on social
distancing are enforced
and i'm particularly grateful to the
police for the work that they're doing
on
expanding that enforcement directly
answering
your question we have ensured
through the clinical advice that we've
taken that
the vaccine rollout goes through those
who are most
at risk first so any police officer
who is aged over 50 will be part of the
initial rollout
through the current groups down to uh
through
what are we what are called the jcvi
cohorts one to nine from the joint
committee on vaccinations and
immunizations which
advises us on the clinical
basis for the order after that
we will then look at what order we go
next
and we'll consider for instance
questions of
people who are in professions where you
might be have to be in contact with more
people
and the impact of the vaccine on
transmission
and make a decision and publicize it as
soon as we've made that decision
no decision has yet been made for where
we'll
go in what order we'll go after the
jcvi cohorts one to nine but we're
looking very closely
including at where the police officers
should be in that order
the next question is from wendy from
london
by text wendy asks will it be possible
for adults to adjust the second dose of
vaccine
to work will it be possible to adjust
the second dose of vaccine to work more
effectively
against the new variants or could a
booster be required
next autumn uh jbt definitely one for
you
yes so thank you i think i've kind of
framed the answer to your question
in terms of really it's more likely to
be the booster
required next autumn with the new
technologies such as the messenger rna
vaccines
and the adenovirus vector vaccines
that covers pfizer and oxford oxford
astrazeneca
respectively you can move pretty fast
to vary the virus in the vaccine
and we're talking about a matter of
weeks rather than a matter of many
months
nevertheless those vaccines still have
to be
tested in a small scale way to make sure
that the immune response
is the same as with the previous version
and then they have to be produced
so i think the notion in your question
wendy of
adjusting the second dose to work more
effectively
is probably not one that's realistic
but an autumn booster if required is
very much
on our radar but just to repeat the
point again
your question kind of implies that the
vaccines we've got
aren't going to work against the virus
we have
that is not true the
the virus we have is the virus first
identified in kent
b 1.117 and
the the vaccines we have are almost
certain
to work against that virus
thanks very much uh professor van tam
next question is from fergus walsh at
the
bbc fergus thanks very much question for
professor van tan do you think it will
be possible
to keep the south african variant
largely suppressed
in the uk and also what would your
message be to people
who may just see fairly scary headlines
about vaccine about virus variants
and their potential effect on the
efficacy of vaccines
so thank you fergus we have small
numbers of the south african variant in
the uk at the present time
and as i've said i'm not seeing and
the early modelling data do not suggest
a a transmissibility advantage for this
virus
so that being the case it's not going to
kind of
overrun or overtake the current
b117 1.117 virus
in the next few months or that is the
most likely scenario that it won't
happen
now so from that perspective
i don't think that this is something
that we should
be concerned about right at this point
in time
and i agree with you that the stories
and the headlines around variant
viruses and vaccines are a bit scary
and i wish they weren't we
are watching this and i said before that
the watch word is vigilance and behind
the scenes for
many weeks now the focus of my work has
been on
thinking over the horizon and thinking
about
what preparations do we need to
put in place to give us a long-term
resilient
vaccine orientated solution to this
problem
and that includes the potential for
variant vaccines for the autumn
thanks very much fergus the clear
message from
both the the clinical community and the
nhs and from others as ministers is that
when
you're offered the jab please get the
jab and if you're 70 or over
then now please come forward to get the
job if you haven't got your appointment
book
booked yet thanks very much the next
question
is from libby vena itv
his question for the secretary of state
um mr hancock
if we can't stop transmission through
vaccination what is the plan are we
going to have to live with a large
number of cases of coronavirus for years
to come
or are we going to go for an elimination
strategy as for example has happened
in new zealand and the question for
professor fantam if i may
um is surge testing underway for both
the south african
variant and the mutated version of the
united kingdom variant
and how many cases have actually been
picked up what is the latest data
on those variants thanks very much well
libby the answer is really clear
that we have a high degree of confidence
that the vaccine
will work to to make people safe
and it is vitally important that people
come forward for their
vaccine we have a plan for
what to do if we need to
update the vaccines to work on the
new variants but we also have a plan to
keep those
new variants under control and keep them
suppressed
and currently the number of new variants
that have been
identified is 147.
so as you can see that's a relatively
small number
compared to the about 20 000 a day of
the
old variant that we're getting and 147
is in total
over the past uh two months since these
first started to appear
um and in fact there have been no new
cases in the last
two days so we are currently
working very hard to suppress those
using the enhanced
testing and isolation at the same time
as making sure that in the future we
will have the vaccines available to
to tackle any new variant that comes
along
all that means that we can protect
people and we are going to be able to
take steps as the number of cases comes
down as the numbers in hospital
come down but it's it's too soon to say
anything more on the timings
of those right now joe professor van tan
secretary i'm not sure i can really add
to your answer other than to say that
the
uk has really probably the
the the largest amount of um sequencing
capacity
anywhere in the world and that
although with the number of cases we
have right now
it is not possible to sequence every
single
case of coronavirus identified through
testing
there will come a point when these
figures
start to fall dramatically where we will
be able to
sequence pretty much everything that we
pick up
but sorry could i just come back on that
are we are we aiming for eliminating
coronavirus or are we going to have to
live with cases in the community for
years to come well of course
everybody would like this disease to be
completely eliminated from this earth
but
we have to make sure that we are
vigilant against it and both coming in
from abroad with the work that we're
doing at the borders where we've
strengthened measures
and also the action that we're taking
here
where the vaccine adds a huge weapon in
our
arsenals as a society for how we can
of how we can deal with this um we as
professor van tan was setting out there
is work underway on whether
a booster is needed and on that i'd
point you to
how we deal with flu each year flu is
dealt with
through an annual jab and the jab is
updated
each year according to the the mutations
and variations that have happened and
been spotted
uh in the in the preceding
few months and then is manufactured over
the summer
and then delivered into the arms of
those who are most vulnerable to flu
in the autumn and so we need to be
thinking about how
to protect people in a similar way
should a should we have a similar
approach
in the future but for now
it's really important that the message
is absolutely crystal clear
to everybody watching this tonight which
is that
when the call comes get a jab the good
news is that if you're 70 or over
and you haven't yet had got that
appointment booked
then come to us and come to the nhs and
we'll get that appointment booked in
ahead of deadline on the 15th
and then we are we're doing the longer
term work
that's needed to make sure that
everybody's protected i hope that
answers the question
um professor libby i think i've kind of
got where you're aiming at last here so
the key thing is to think about to frame
this in terms of
how we manage seasonal flu and we manage
it
every winter and we manage it through
vaccination
and we manage it through making sure
that the disease burden doesn't
overwhelm
our hospitals the key with this
coronavirus is again through vaccination
to take the whole curve and shift it
to the left so the majority
the vast majority of the illness is
an illness that is manageable in the
community
as opposed to causing enormous pressure
on our hospitals
and we can do that through vaccination
and if we do that
we open up a whole way of living
normally
or much more normally again in the
future so that for me is really the key
shifting the whole curve to the left if
you like
away from the hospitals and into a
manageable community illness
through vaccination
thanks very much indeed uh victoria
mcdonald from channel 4.
uh thank you secretary of state um
you've just described the
testing program as growing at a
blistering rate
and you've praised contact tracing and
yet there are numerous reports of
contact traces that call centers being
made
redundant and in fact we have spoken to
one who said that they'd been
reassured that they would have work
until may only to be told that their
jobs will go
next week so why is this happening right
now and
is this wise right at the moment
well as i say the performance of the nhs
test and trace has been absolutely
fantastic and we know that it took
time to build up and we always said that
it would take time
but now with those figures of the
turnaround times 98
within the net within uh of contacts
reached
within 24 hours and 97 in total of
contacts reached where we have those
contact details so it is
performing extremely well uh of course
we're
we're constantly working to ensure that
it delivers
that very very high quality performance
and in fact we're putting more resources
into
the areas where we have significant
concern where there's a
variant of concern so it is performing
absolutely
brilliantly and i'm very very proud of
all the people who are
who are doing that um and the good news
is
that also because the number of cases is
coming down
so the number of people who are positive
and therefore the number of contacts
is also coming down too thanks very much
the next question is from kate ferguson
at the sun
hi this is a question for you mr hancock
and professor john van tan
there's been calls for the return of the
rule of six outside from next month
i wondered can you give brits any hopes
that this could happen
and israel is outdoor group exercise
and socializing one of the safer
restrictions to ease first
kate is very tempting to get into this
but we're not going to get into this
at all it is too early to say and it is
too early to speculate
on any of the measures that we might be
able to take
the prime minister has set out that he
will he will publish a road map
uh on the 22nd of february take into
account
all that we know uh by then uh and uh i
think we'll have to leave it there
and we we're not getting into any
speculation about what might happen next
uh thanks very much jess elliot from the
guardian
hi there and secretary of state the the
prime minister said today that strict
border controls are actually more
effective
once a country has a very low internal
infection rate
so therefore should people be prepared
for to be very tough
perhaps even tougher restrictions on
travel until there is
widespread international vaccination and
are we talking about months or maybe
even years
of that and all another professor van
time if i may um
brits have been cautioned by ministers
and by scientists that it's too early to
book any summer holiday abroad this year
would you say that it's also too early
for people to book summer holidays
particularly those with other households
within the uk i know we've talked about
a great british summer
but now we know that a third booster jab
might be needed in the autumn
well thanks very much uh thanks very
much jess um the
the fact that we only have seen 147
cases that we know of of um
of of new variants here other than the
kent variant
where on from on which we know we have a
high degree of confidence that
the current vaccines work um means that
we need to protect the country from
new variants but also that those numbers
are really very low
and hence the the toughening that we
took last month to measures at the
border
and we're on track to deliver on the
stronger border measure still
from countries particularly of concern
by next monday
um the the reason it's important to get
this set up now
is that the proportion of cases coming
from abroad at the moment is obviously
very low
not least because it is currently
illegal to go on holiday
anyway and of course we want to lift
these measures as with all the other
measures as soon as is safely possible
but until we know we need to know more
about the impact of the vaccines
on all these different variants and
therefore
for now the precautionary principle is
the right approach
i don't know whether dr khannani or
professor
vantam thanks for the question and
and i can't answer it um you know i
think
it's just too early to say we don't
yet have the readouts on the success of
the vaccine program
though i expect we just start to see
those within one to two weeks
public health countermeasures
non-pharmaceutical interventions
social distancing restrictions they
will have to be released gradually
how quickly they can be released will
depend upon
three things the virus the vaccine
and the extent to which the public obey
the rules that are in place
which thankfully the vast majority
always do
and then really the more elaborate your
plans are for
summer holidays in terms of crossing
borders in terms of household mixing
given where we are now i think you just
have to say you're more you're stepping
into
you know making guesses about the
unknown at this point
and so i can't give people a proper
answer at this point because we don't
yet have
the data it's just too early
thanks very much jess and final question
is from alex rogers
of my london and yorkshire live alex
good evening matt hancock you've
announced a significant increase in
testing to reach businesses today
will small businesses in particular
early years and child care providers who
have been fully open
throughout the lockdown get any help to
test their staff
will employers be expected to pay for
tests for their staff and how much will
it cost them
and my second question is 147 cases of
the south african variant
have been identified in the uk including
three areas of london as previously
reported
has surge testing successfully contain
the variant from spreading beyond those
three areas
and if not where else in the capital has
it been found
thanks very much on the second part of
your question um thus far we
have not found any further extension
and when we do including whether that's
through the extra testing that we've put
in
um or through the uh the core
uh testing system uh we will absolutely
publish that
um and it is um uh it's very important
that we
publish that as quickly as possible so
that people in that local area know that
there's a
know that there's a challenge on the
first part of your
um your question um
the it's completely slipped my mind
you're gonna have to ask it again i
apologize
okay sorry um i was saying
thank you um uh you've been you've
announced a significant increase in
testing to reach businesses
for small businesses in particular early
years and child care providers who've
been fully open through the lockdown
will they get any help to test their
stuff yes will they be willing
be expected to pay for it and how much
will it cost them yes
so this testing is free for now uh
and we're always looking to who we can
expand this
testing to and um so i want in the same
way that we've been tested we've
expanded
it to the nhs to
schools uh to hundreds of
large employers we now want to expand it
to employers of more than 50
and obviously look at how much further
we can go after that and uh the point
that you make about
uh those providing child care is an
important one
and uh is is part of our plans and
we'll set out details um in due course i
don't know whether um
uh dr khanna you want to say something
about the this expansion across the nhs
because the the regular testing has been
used in the nhs as probably one of the
first places that it went to
yes and we've seen the effectiveness yes
absolutely so we've been um
uh using uh what's called the lateral
flow testing and asymptomatic
asymptomatic testing um across the nhs
for some time now expanding into primary
care
um so that is into general practice
pharmacy dentistry optometry
and so people have been getting used to
testing uh twice a week to make sure
that they can
um keep well and obviously having a
subsequent test if they need it
and have adopted that really well so
it's something to be recommended
thanks very much indeed that ends the uh
the coronavirus daily briefing for
uh today thank you
there we are matt hancock they're urging
all those over 70 who have not had a jab
to come forward and have one by booking
it through
the nhs directly or through their gp
and on variants jonathan van tam on the
south african variant clearly wanted to
calm
concern saying the south african variant
is not anything like the dominant virus
he said
and no reason to think it will catch up
uh the main current virus and plenty of
evidence he said that existing vaccines
are effective against
that virus and existing vaccines stop
serious illness
from the south african variant
i'm joined now by the former chief
scientific advisor and member of sage
sir mark walport thank you very much for
being with us uh so soon after that
uh news conference so let's just put
this south african variant in
perspective what are the implications
in your view of these trials showing a
limited effectiveness of the oxford
vaccine against the
south african variant well i mean the
first thing to say is it's not
only the oxford vaccine that's showing
less effectiveness we know from clinical
studies of the other vaccines that they
seem to be a bit less effective as well
what we know about the az oxford vaccine
is that it doesn't appear to stop
mild or moderate disease in a young
population
what we don't know about at this stage
is whether it will actually prevent the
sort of severe disease leading to
hospitalization and potentially death
in older populations we know that it
mounts
a similar level of antibody response to
other vaccines
the the azid vaccine so we just don't
know at this stage is the answer
right um sorry no
go on the important thing is yeah well
just to recognize where we are in the uk
as you heard in the the press conference
from matt hancock where
you know we've now got over 12 million
people vaccinated we are learning new
things about the az vaccine
all the time we know now that a single
dose
is effective uh in preventing over 76
percent of
uh protection um for the first 12 weeks
um and that the vaccine does appear to
stop reduce asymptomatic infection
during that period as well
so we're learning new stuff all the time
but the reality is that we're only going
to really know what happens when we
vaccinate we immunize populations at
scale
when we've actually done it right and
does it raise concerns that it won't
stop the spread of the virus
so effectively is that is that a problem
leading from that's certainly a problem
with the south african variant and
that's what people are concerned about
so as i said the evidence is that it
doesn't prevent
mild or moderate infection and that
means that people who have those
infections can spread it to others
and so it is a concern and again the
good news is that the south african
variant appears to be extremely uncommon
in the uk only 147 cases have been
identified so far
that there may well be unidentified
almost certainly are unidentified
infections as well and it's why uh
as the virus evolves uh we need to make
sure that the vaccine is adapted to be
able to deal with the new variants as
they emerge
as they surely will right and the prime
minister saying we've gained the upper
hand over the virus
um is that is that true
well i i mean i think these methods are
a bit difficult
viruses can mutate very very quickly uh
much more quickly than
humans so uh really getting the upper
hand is quite challenging but
vaccines are a very very powerful tool
and it is extraordinary that so many
good vaccines have been developed in
such a short
space of time it is but it will require
constant vigilance
yeah and on that point i mean the
pressure will be on because the vaccine
rollout is going so well
to relax things soon in the next couple
of months
are we okay to do that given this sort
of variant problem
no we're definitely not okay to do that
because uh the reality is that we have
very high case numbers still
as we had before the bed occupancy in
hospitals is still
well above the level the peak that it
reached in april during the first wave
of the pandemic
there are still many cases in the
community and
if we're really going to get track and
trace and isolate work most effectively
that's got to be done on a background of
much reduced case numbers and equally
the more we can reduce case numbers
around the world
the less the opportunity that the virus
has to mutate and spread in the future
and so we really have got to remain
active and vigilant
and keep numbers under control and were
we to relax
immediately the truth is that even when
we vaccinated
everyone of 50 and above and the people
who look after them
that's still about half the population
that isn't vaccinated
and a major epidemic amongst them would
cause a lot of misery and illness as
well
so it could be another difficult year um
just looking at what sort of
restrictions could be in place
next winter or this time next year do
you think i mean i think that it's
you know extremely difficult to predict
the future if everything goes well
and we get numbers down uh then it
should be possible to gradually relax
the restrictions and you know lockdown
isn't an all or nothing thing
and so we've got to see how the case
numbers come down
how effective the vaccine is in keeping
people out of hospital
and then we can you know measures can be
relaxed on a
stage-by-stage basis it's not an all or
nothing thing
and just a quick one 30 seconds i mean a
lot of chat
about travel this summer i mean and
closing
not closing borders but quarantine being
more effective
um how does it look to you this summer
well again
it makes sense to try and limit the
spread of new variants
and that does involve people traveling
less
and so it probably doesn't make too much
sense to be booking your holidays abroad
at a time when
as jonathan van tam just said it's
impossible to give these answers
okay so mark warport appreciate